《红楼》第四十三回,政治王熙凤九月初二生日,贾宝为了新鲜热闹提出凑分子的想法。让各位准备小姐,以及有体面的吓人一起凑钱,无论多寡以此作为举办生日宴的资金。但在凑钱过程中,存在一些模糊不清的状况。
按照原住所记,家母学一妈每人二十两,王夫人、新夫人、每人十六两,就是四位长辈出的赢字数。
到了同备人,李丸优势每人十二两,其中李丸的十二两,先是家母要带出,又被王熙凤蓝住讨好,要自己替李丸出钱,所以李丸的十二两可以忽略不计。
有体面的老年摩摩,比如賴大之母这些人,虽然身份低威却迫有家资。
在家母的坚持下,他们也跟李丸优势一例,每人十二两,其余的压坏,如评论,冤养,习人等,一两二两不等。
以上的凑分子信息是明确的,模糊不清的情况恰恰出现在,各位经拆身上。
曹雪琴在描述各位小姐时说的不够明确,甚至连人数都出现了疑问。
我们先来看援助的描述。
众丫头婆子见家母十分高兴,也都高兴,茫茫的各自分头去,请得请传的传。
没顿犯的功夫,老得少得上得下得,无丫丫挤了一屋子,只需一妈和家母对做。
形服人王夫人只坐在房门前两张椅子上,保拆子妹等五六个人坐在抗上,
保育坐在家母怀前,地下满满的站了一地。
这里很奇怪,曹雪琴在描述小姐们的人数时说的是,保拆子妹等五六个人。
布红君初读时觉得很奇怪,因为小姐们的人数是明确且固定的。
五个就是五个,六个就是六个,为什么非要模糊一下说成五六个人。
我们不妨来一一列举一下小姐们的人数。
操工既然用保拆子妹等开头,说明其中必然不包括李丸,否则李丸作为大嫂子应该放在手位。
那么实际的小姐人数应该包括,学宝拆零代域,假营村,假碳村,假西村,一共五个人。
这也是后来实际出钱的人数。
那么曹宫为什么要说五六个人?
布红君思以为,操雪琴之所以用五六个人是因为有一个人很难计算在内,这个人就是史乡云。
我们联系前文,史乡云自第37回海唐师社就来到了荣国府。
其后第38回,庞谢宴,居花师,史乡云更是主角。
第39回,第40回,刘老老进大官员,家母也趁便给史乡云还习。
直到第42回,刘老老离开荣国府,史乡云都还在家府内并未离开。
故而,林代欲说,刘老老生母皇宠,又给西村所话,大官员行乐图起名为,邪皇大教图时,史乡云笑得从椅子上滚下来。
这些都说明,史乡云一直都在中国府。
经接着到了第43回,先娶乐欧川金庆授,家母为王西放凑钱过生日,这中间并未说史乡云离开了假假。
所以鳳姐生日时,史乡云明显应该在假假,她也应该跟着一起湊钱。
既然如此,曹雪琴就应该明确一些,直接邪,保拆子妹等六个人,为什么要邪五六个人?
原因就在于,史乡云只存在于时间线里,如果在书中寻找她的宗计,那是完全找不到的。
布红君对史乡云这个人物进行检索,她第42回还出现过一次,便是因林代欲说,邪皇大教图笑得跌倒了椅子,之后就完全消失了。
她下一次出现,居然已经是第49回,流离世界白雪红梅。
计计是,保林侯时奈签了外省大云,家母舍不得史乡云,就留下乡云在家府长居。
也就是说,史乡云这个人物的出现是断裂性的,这就导致在许多情节里,按照时间线,史乡云应该存在,可观照情节,史乡云则完全不存在。
就以王岐峰生日为例,第42回时史乡云还在,书中也没说史乡云回家,那么我们独者自然默认,史乡云一直还在容国府。
王岐峰生日,众节没要凑钱,自然史乡云也要出钱,可我们会惊讶地发现,再尝所有人都忘记了史乡云的存在,我们看援助此断。
峰节又笑到,我想老祖宗自己二十两又有临妹妹保兄弟的两份子,一妈自己二十两又有宝妹妹的一份子,这倒也公道,只是二位太太每位十六两,自己又少又不替人出,这有些不公道,老祖宗吃了亏了。
甲母听了蒙笑道,倒是我的峰节向着我,这说得很适,要不是你我叫他们又哄了去了,峰节笑道,老祖宗只把他结儿两个交给两位太太,一位站一个,派多派少,每位替出一份就试了,甲母蒙说这很公道就是这样。
按照峰节的说法,甲母不仅要出自己的份子钱,还会替保育待遇处,学一妈也会替女儿保拆处,所以王夕峰建议,让王府认刑夫认也替结儿两个各出一份钱,这里的结儿两个不宏军个人以为,应该指的是营春和探春。
因为刑夫认是营春名义上的母亲,王府认是探春名义上的母亲,母亲替女儿出份子钱,峰节的建议完全合情合理。
最后只剩下一个西纯,但他是宁国府的人,或许因他年龄小不用出钱,意或者他的嫂子有事会替他出钱,总之书中并没有提及西纯,我们也只能按下不提。
唯独使相云的份子钱,压根没有人提起,甚至使相云这三个字在此回根本就没出现过。
如果使相云此时真的在荣国府,那么他的份子钱,大概率会由甲母来出。
因为使相云能中修色,又是甲母娘家的孩子,使老太君不会如此不顾相云的感受。
综合以上分析,不宏君认为,红楼梦使相云的时间线可能存在残缺的问题。
最合理的解释是,第四十二回,刘老老离开荣国府后,使相云应该也被接回使家了,所以第四十二回,至第四十九回,他都彻底消失。
直到宝林侯时代签了外省,甲母才要求使家留下相云,使相云才得以继续出现。
可按照金本红楼梦的时间线,第四十二回,并没有说使相云回家,所以草决情或是后来的改搞者,觉得使相云既然没有回家,自然应该出现在凑钱的人群中。
可书中情节又完全没有相云,导致写五个子妹不合适,写六个子妹也不合理,就干脆写成了五六个子妹。
从这一处小小的细节,就能亏探修改者的苦心,令人称探。
今天的红楼解读就聊到这里,我们下个视频再会。